das ist im prinzip prinzip so dass wir
das jetzt für diesen stoff direkt nur
verträglichkeits daten für einige monate
haben wir werden auch über die nächsten
zwei jahre verträglichkeit daten sammeln
ich glaube allgemein muss man sagen dass
die impfstoff nebenwirkungen die wird
alle allermeisten innenstadt
nebenwirkungen
in den ersten vier bis sechs wochen nach
impfung auftreten und danach rapide an
frequenz verlieren
dementsprechend erwarte ich mir bei
unserem impfstoff war keine
überraschungen
man kann aber niemals ausschließen das
langzeit nebenwirkungen auftreten
könnten
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist gering aber
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir auch
weiterhin verträglichkeits datensammeln
in der zwischenzeit sind ja in england
in den usa und kanada gab einige und
weiteren menschen immunisiert worden
diese menschen haben nur einer injektion
bisher bekommen
das was wir bisher als rückmeldung haben
ist ist das das dem
verträglichkeitsprofil entspricht
welches in dieser großen und
kontrollierten studien mit über 40.000
personen gesehen worden sind es sind ja
einige schwere allergien detektiert
worden
wie hoch die frequenz ist wissen wenn
ich es scheint im bereich von 1 50.000
zulegen
und wenn das der fall wäre ist das auch
nicht unüblich so genannte rekombinante
impfstoffe die tatsächlich und mit
allergien in dieser frequenz zu rechnen
bei denen auch alle gehen in dieser
verkürzten erfolgen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren